are you ready yeah let's go okay all
right ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your favorite podcast you know the
name you can't really sing though well
you know I I feel so disadvantaged
because I feel like it should be deeply
imprinted in my DNA to sing and dance I
know you should have a singing machine
at your place I do okay when you when
you were growing up you had to sing a
machine vases with vases I think you
said that the last time when I was
growing up all my friends were Filipino
you had one okay no no all my friends
from high school were Filipino like when
I was growing up I had like all these
Filipino friends and I would go to their
house and they would have like Jesus and
like that place was full of vases and
like the different sizes and they had
all different types of rice dispensers
and and like you know big huge rice
cookers I didn't have the rice
dispensers where I came from we had to
pull it out the sack oh you had to do
that - are you aiming me anyway first of
all welcome to the podcast how do you
say your last name Khan kun
why don't we never ever say my last name
I'm just kalila okay oh no oh you're
like jack-ay now no madonna
you're like Madonna
oh my god this is a nightmare a monster
how do you say it cool hyun-joon but the
reason I never tell anybody is because
you're not gonna remember I never why is
it spelled KH UN that's how you say kyun
it's K uhm hey you even still oh you're
right ku
yeah and it's supposed to have like an
umlaut on top of the Oh cute I see now k
you aged cuz at home yeah can you hear
me okay yeah you fine you don't need
yourself great no but it's fine as long
as you hear me oh okay yeah really good
okay everybody always has like a this is
not good I don't have a Gilbert there's
no George over here right notes it's
just me I'm really impressed of your
setup well I mean I also Clinton this
should be like more wires right here it
was like I'm gonna get a I'm gonna get a
rug right here so you don't even see any
of that you know because people are cut
you know I'm usually like a really
private person so I don't let people
come over to my place I don't I don't
have gay gatherings I just I'm just a
private my little bachelor condo thing
here I don't I don't but now I was like
you know what let me do my podcast here
let me open this up you know and let
people come over Bobby comes over and
the first thing he does is he talks [ __ ]
then he has some secret Tiger belly
podcast where he's talking [ __ ] about my
place like I'm some kind of like I'm it
living in like a weird you know I mean
that's why I was like this is why I
don't let people over but I was like let
me just let the [ __ ] go gasps Bobby
that's who he is so you've been to our
storage facility that's Church that's
half this size but housed a new place
that like the new place is it like is it
already messy you know you got a zoo
already you know I really value the time
when Bobby's out of town because it's my
time to deep clean it's my time to
actually like enjoy the house for all
its potential because once he's back
it's just rappers and sticky juice
bottles by the bed you know oh you bet
he eats in bed he drinks he likes to
have his apocalypse necks at the side of
his bed just in case you know there's an
earthquake in the middle the night and
he needs a snack so there's like crumbs
and
yeah and it's just this is a hole that
we can we get it we're getting the
inside right now the stuff that he can't
get in the way of I don't know I do
thank you for coming on you know I'm so
sick of people you know it's like once I
put it Bobby and Steve on the podcast
together doing the movie thing we did it
twice and I was like I I'm still trying
to have them come do it but it's just
hard to get them together now so then
every day people like did you guys
supposed to do it once a month
yes that's not a big ass who you telling
you're telling me I got like I don't
know that that's not I've been you know
and then I can't get them together and
then all that [ __ ] happened so they were
like kind of fighting and then like it
there's always something yeah you know
and now they're you know they died so
they're dealing with that and they're
still you know there's always some kind
of turmoil in their lives
yeah even though they're still doing
their podcasts yeah so they just don't
have the bandwidth to add another one so
you know so I I have that every day
somebody's like when is Bobby and you
know okay
now on top of that it's when you and you
work along as you do the podcast when is
Scooby and lashes gonna start happening
well I don't know we haven't even I've
been out of town she's been dealing with
Bobby and his this family like it again
it's like it's always a mess and then I
have to on top of that I have to deal
with like red and yellow Eric still be
the [ __ ] let it Bobby in and you do
their podcast why are you being like
that every day or it's like oh you and
Bobby would be better or like you know I
have to deal with this every day
nobody's like yeah murmuring and about
my podcast they just talking about what
I should be doing my podcast or like
what I should be doing with other people
so it's just it's just I don't think
it's that bad i I at least you don't get
gold-digging [ __ ] at least six times a
day you know what you know what I feel
so much better now
I think you have it pretty good yeah
gold-digging yeah that I you know what I
actually get that on people say you know
yeah you'd be better than that Goldie
[Laughter]
you gotta stop saying that no that stuff
doesn't bother me I wouldn't be laughing
about it if it if it bothered me what
does bother you not a lot these days
not anything yeah you can do how could
you let anything bother you with with
Bobby in your life and in fact I think I
I think the you know I think the trolls
for really thickening my skin in ways I
never thought I could do on my own
that's so true they've given me a deeper
understanding and a deeper it's just
they're they're not it's just a
projection it's not it's never it's
never really about you it really just is
a projection and I had you know I talked
to a troll I interviewed my troll oh we
want a patreon episodes [ __ ] either you
want me to pay to watch I could have
given you the audio so you interviewed a
troll that's a good idea
yeah how did I go really well he was a
really bright nice young man who lived a
very normal life and you know he
couldn't really figure out what about me
upset him besides like the the in person
he couldn't or like over I'm sure he
couldn't cuz because when you call those
people out they oftentimes are like I
can't believe this is happening
yeah and it wasn't about like I I I know
I'm not supposed as a cardinal rule
right like never give him any you know
air time right right right but I
genuinely wanted to know why you was
saying as much as he was saying and he
didn't know it either so I came to the
conclusion that you know like you know
whatever once a month now I really liked
him you say like if Bobby wasn't around
no I I a genuine
we connected with him know he's somebody
that I think that I would have been
friends with in a different lifetime if
there was something about you obviously
that like he was like I don't know why I
don't I don't get it I don't know what
inspires people to write these things
but for me I learned I have to let it go
because when you read what they say you
want a reason with them sometimes you go
you don't understand what I'm talking
about you don't know all the facts and
they just say these things yeah and then
you just like okay but it's because they
don't understand that they say those
things and you can't expect them to
understand it the way you do so you
they're only seeing a very shallow
version of you no matter how much you
give of yourself in a podcast there are
only really seeing two percent they
don't know the ins and outs of your day
they don't know what you look like when
you're genuinely upset they don't think
you guys give a lot on the podcast I
almost want to say you guys give too
much on the podcast of the part how do
you feel about that well this is great
like the inside of life like you you
guys get so personal more than anyone
else you guys don't even you might not
even realize it what do you think about
that I'll tell you the drawbacks of
being really personal especially about
your sex life is that I have rendered
sexuality like I have a very it's
backfired on me because Here I am being
so pragmatic about about the way I speak
about sex and being so open and
seemingly unaffected by you know all the
crazy things that are happening in my
life but I've talked it to the point of
I'm bored of the idea of sex anytime I
hear people talk about sex I don't I
don't giggle anymore I don't have I
don't have feelings towards the topic of
sex because we've talked it dead we've
talked it to the point of it being so
like just overdone there's nothing
mystical about it anymore there's
nothing excited about it anymore
yeah well has it affected your own
personal sex life because of that oh
yeah I mean like we've told everybody
about the types of you know role-playing
we've done and where I'm like no [ __ ]
like I got to come up with
new characters but is it a point we like
you you're out at a restaurant and
people like say the character name you
start but does that make sense
yeah no no I totally does it totally
does I totally understand like you know
it's like this thing of like being so
vulnerable and open and sometimes you I
get this a lot from my close friends who
watch my podcast and they'll say to me
I'm a I didn't know that about you I've
never heard that story before or I never
knew that about you and so like you guys
have as I've watched a few episodes or
whatever it's like damn you guys really
go that's just nature Bobby me knowing
Bobby like he's such an open book and
he's roped me into that right regrets
parts of it but mostly it has it is very
freeing I don't know it's a weird like
paradox it's a it's freeing but it also
feels like a prison where it's like
you're no one can hold all of this over
your head but everyone can hold this
over your head yes I am NOT I haven't
thought about it or haven't been in it
long enough to know what the end effect
is but but it's it's a weird place to be
but I I do appreciate this about Bobby
is that he made me a lot more unafraid
to just say it to own it and whatever
consequence comes out of it just deal
with it you know like I don't I don't I
don't like see I it's made me less
afraid of my own secrets right right you
know what I mean yes yes yes yeah that's
because when you say people hold it over
your head I think it's the kind of thing
where it's about it can only be held
over your head if you're ashamed of it
exactly right yeah and that's something
about him for sure that he doesn't seem
to be ashamed of anything and even if he
feels some shame he doesn't let it it's
not gonna affect him to the point where
well that's it I'm gonna like laughter
like leave society there I you're right
it doesn't he doesn't let it fester I'm
not there yet I do let things fester oh
so just just so it's what you're saying
to me right now is that this does bother
you like you're you're but you're
weighing the benefits
the rewards the adulation the money and
that's like that kind of stuff is wade
up against like how it's affecting your
personality and your and your psyche
I'll tell you this right now I am you
can ask me anything about the the deep
cavernous area of my cervix
every little ribbed and you you want to
see it you want to stick your head up
there be my guest
but the one thing that I am still trying
to that I have shame about is the whole
career nursing thing that I just don't
want to talk about and I always like if
anyone brings it up I deflect and that's
because I right before I met Bobby I
turn down the job you know and I called
myself a nurse because I finished the
program and I graduated but I besides
you know being a student and spending
two years in a hospital as a student I
never worked at the place that I was
supposed to as a nurse you know what I
mean well suppose to was a weird word
but yeah cuz I that's imagine that like
you can stick your head up into my
cervix and I have no shame about that
but if anyone were to bring that up
about the whole nursing thing it really
strikes the chord and it make it I feel
really shameful that I didn't see that
through well it's interesting because
like I didn't bring it up you you
actually brought it up it's been
festering that's why well this is good
talk about it I mean I think to this
like like because it's like because like
what do you think you know did you think
you weren't gonna be good enough to be a
nurse no I was great and I was great
during my nursing program and this is
gonna sound so stupid and petty mm-hm
but the reason I felt justified and not
being a nurse because I was really bad
with my hands my hands are sweaty I
couldn't put on gloves and I remember my
last clinical rotation as it sounds
petty but there was an emergent
situation I needed to see a patient who
was decompensating and I tried to put on
my gloves because it was I couldn't air
it I could not put on my gloves really
did you
did you not are you saying you
physically couldn't physically put on so
wasn't like a mental thing with you oh
no my hands were sweating uh-huh but
isn't there something that you could get
for that oh yeah I had Botox on my hands
for six years to the point where they at
your feet in my muscles at work anymore
got you or I couldn't even properly hold
a pen and I don't want to say that out
loud because it's all so dumb and
everyone's oh it's great baby powder
you're not all first of all first of all
it's not dumb to me it just sounds like
you wanted to be great at the job and
this was something that was holding you
back and you are feeling a certain way
about that you let this limitation hold
you back you seem to have not forgiven
yourself for that are you a
perfectionist I am and I think that's
because I was beat as a child
relentlessly by my mother where if I
made just a small wrong turn it was the
end of the world and I got my ass beat
so I I don't I have if I know that I
can't see it through to the end
perfectly I'm not even gonna bother and
I've tried to change that over the year
but yeah over the last couple of years
I've acknowledged that about myself
right no no it's just brave it's like
that's uh it's not brave to say you
can't [ __ ] work as a nurse because
you have sweaty hands
no no because that's not what it is what
it is is like the trauma of trying to be
perfect by this standard that your mom
set for you she's still with you
yeah you know she just like everything
that you're doing she's with you so that
was one of those things that even if
it's something small in your mind you
heard your mom like yeah she was beating
you in the hospital but metaphorically
so I mean why haven't you so you haven't
forgiven yourself no and I have a lot I
carry a big bag of shame about that
because about the nursing thing well
yeah because I tell everyone a different
story I tell everyone I met Bobby and he
gave me this you know big avenue to be
creative and that's just what I chose
over nursing but the point is I couldn't
I
I was so good in theory as a nurse where
I could give you all the pathology of
anything but I couldn't
physically work with my hand why did you
become a nurse um because I couldn't
become a doctor I couldn't live with the
idea of being in that much debt why did
you want to be a doctor I had always
been fascinated and really really just
medicine was my thing
you know I that's what my that's what I
was good at I was always very good in
the sciences I was a biochemistry major
no room and I tutored in both Community
College and in university as a
microbiology tutor as an anatomy
physiology tutor was there any pressure
from your parents for your mom to be
like I want you to be a doctor as their
other doctors in your family yeah my dad
got his heat my dad that's another thing
following the footsteps of my dad but
not quite as great he was an MD but
never practice so he finished medical
school but never practice some wise I'm
rich King oh so he didn't really want to
do it he was a rich kid that ended up
doing other things and creative things
no excuse married three times
oh okay no I'm just trying to find out
like so you know digging deep sweating
no one asks me these things
hi you want me to ask you these things
so all right I feel like you're the only
one who'll listen I listen to you I get
it so you want it to be so so if you had
to ask yourself honestly did you really
want to be a doctor were those things
really interesting to you or was it the
fact that your dad was a doctor and
that's why you became just really
interesting to me I still have dreams of
going back to school and why don't you
not being a medical doctor but getting I
don't know maybe something along the
lines of like I don't know other things
just not but there's so many different
fields like you don't have to have a
scalpel in your hand but you could be
like a pathologist you could be like you
know you could you know you could be a
researcher or medical researcher there's
so many types of things like that have
you ever honestly thought about it and
think like you know and maybe I can
really because you actually can do it I
can do it yeah it's just about whether I
want to commit you know a certain amount
of years to it now right
and but yeah I I think about it all the
time I think about it probably at least
three times a day the why then what's
stopping you because do you really want
to have that regret I don't know if I
can sustain the life that I have now if
I fully immerse myself back into being a
student because when I'm a student I'm
full I'm a student and I don't know what
the repercussions will be on my
relationship on my life and you know
like I I take care of Bobby a lot right
so that scares you
I I don't know how much time I can offer
him if I all of a sudden fall in love
with being a student again mm-hmm well
then well then well is there any is
there anything in you to learn
moderation yeah yeah maybe we'll see
they're all perfectionism doesn't allow
for moderation it's either you're all in
or you're not but see that's a you
problem
it's a me problem yeah well I mean I
feel like I feel like there there's got
to be a medium of like you know cuz I'd
hate for you to have this unfulfilled
thing because then it's gonna build
resentment then you're gonna like later
you're gonna be like blaming him no no
that'll never do this is something that
I I know is very me thing I would never
throw that on him and in fact he's
always said yeah go back to school he's
never he's never you know he's never not
let me fly well then how crazy is it
then I what are you saying to yourself
right now on my own ship yes it's what I
did my whole life you're my therapist
you tell me no I'm just trying to find
out like like what I'm trying to find
out to navigate this thought process
with you I'm just like I mean I'm this
so interested because I think a lot of
people have these kinds of fears and
insecurities and like they have these
things this baggage from their parents
that like we go why am I like this and
we go like okay so once we can
understand like this is why I'm like
this
now it's about like well how can I
overcome that and I'm hearing from you
that like you actually have a lot of the
things ready to go to get overcome this
you just haven't made that next step
yeah I and you're right and it might be
closer to it then then I think I am yeah
and maybe next year maybe next year I'll
you know pull the trigger and do it well
maybe you should have you thought about
trying like well let me try one class or
let me try like you know let me you know
I mean just to see because maybe there's
like some undergrad class that you can
take that you only had to take like a
couple of some units you know like you
know and then you could like be like oh
look at look at me I'm actually managing
because maybe Bobbi has taught you how
to manage many things yeah and like
because you're not this you're does not
perfection in your life right now you
know so how is it being a perfectionist
with someone that does not allow
perfection yeah yeah that's true I've
learned to really be to practice
tolerance and and you know cleaning a
lot you it's a podcast partner it made
yeah but I bet you you clean though
that's because that's part of your quirk
I just like you can't have a cup just
sitting here you're gonna be it's gonna
stain the one yeah yeah yeah that's what
I'm saying that's dead I'm gonna light
my candles from the hangover candle
company you know I mean since we're
getting like we're getting deep too deep
see I told you that one episode we did
have scorpion lashes cuz it wasn't a
tiger belly episode that was lightning
in a bottle what if we can never
recreate that yeah but this [ __ ] is not
joyous and funny this [ __ ] it's like but
that's not the reason why everybody
watches things to be joyous and funny I
think people just want interesting
conversations and then they listen and
they go and that's how they relate to us
in some way I mean I just find myself
like when I first started doing this I
was doing these solo episodes and I was
like damn how do you be funny like when
I look at Chris D'Elia and Theo I'm like
they're so silly on there just by
themselves talking like you know feels
just like you know then the pig and you
know and I did the thing and then there
was this guy like I don't know why I did
it you know
just the way in it's just as vernacular
and everything people just find that
like oh man this is endearing you know
yeah but I'm just not like that I'm that
way with other when I'm interacting with
other people I find myself but when I'm
doing it by myself do
super Slyke serious and like I'm just
giving my points you know so it just
naturally lends itself to that but I
still think that it still could be
interesting and entertaining I'm not
finding this fascinating what you're
talking about and I do feel like you
want to talk about this I think that
you're around that crazy person so often
that it's like he's that way with me
himself like it's just when it's like
certain moments you know call me and I
just know that all he just needs to like
talk to me about something
yeah not even like he wants my opinion
he just I get him though I get his
quirks and that's why we're friends you
know but like I'm just saying to you
it's like right now it's like I think
that you should use this as an example
that you know your relationship with him
and how it's like changed you maybe
you're not you're not gonna be the
student that you thought you were or
that you need to be maybe it's like have
no expectations and just try this
because if he doesn't work out you
already did that already yeah you went
to school and you didn't follow through
because you did something else that's
still equally as great yeah so then you
could do it again you can try it again
and they'd be like you know what
actually I like my other life yeah you
know and then you'd be like yeah that's
a good point too to even have the
reference to say I prefer one over the
other
yeah how can I even say that how can I
know for sure that this is the life that
I want if I don't try the other one out
yeah that's a good point yeah so I just
say like you know and then like I think
they you just like using cookie I think
that you use your mom as a crutch I do I
think that you I'm thinking this whole
like the little petty things you use
those that you you're propping them up
to be like well I mean I my hands are
sweating so I can't I think that's
something that you know you could
overcome that's just as a science person
you know you can overcome hyperhidrosis
there's nothing I can do about that
well then let's like cut a nerve like
right between 5c you see what I'm saying
you already know all this kind of stuff
yeah but there's good then I'm gonna
you're gonna see me and I'm like
sweating in my earlobes and you're like
why do you have sweat there oh I'm sorry
Eric I have compensatory sweating from
that time you told me to cut the nerve
between my
you said there you even know the
solution no I'm saying you know what
causes it and everything you actually
have a intellectual understanding of
what's happening to you you're actually
like I actually know why my hands sweat
yeah I know some solutions I know some
things to do it's like what I'm saying
is like it doesn't sound like something
that you can't overcome this is just a
mental block that you've put on yourself
you're building your own walls and you
don't have to but I see you're as right
now is just somebody that's like taking
one of the bricks out and you're looking
out like maybe this isn't so bad
you know what that's the one thing that
I wish I I'm a [ __ ] right now in this
stage in my life you're scared I I've
never been more scared than I am now and
I don't understand why when I was a
broke college kid jeez like the
decisions that I made I know we're just
big and reckless but very very rewarding
you know now I just I don't know if I
feel like I have a lot to lose yeah
that's that's what it is
you know fear like I'm at least I just
think fear stops everybody from doing a
lot of things you know like fears like
you know fear of just fear failure feel
the fear of success I think you have a
lot of that to fear of success you know
I have you know what I have I also have
a fear I have I always feel like an
impostor everywhere I go I feel like I
feel like I'm an imposter in this
podcasting world I feel like I'm an
impostor when I you know give any type
of like information or if I spit out
anything I learned in school I you know
I mean like when when you you earlier
you had you said you or you had a guest
that wanted to become an astronaut yeah
well let's say you had an O just not
right they're just they just know their
[ __ ] and because they are that right
they are that podcasting is where you're
like anyone can be a podcaster so and
everyone that I'm surrounded by is like
legitimate comedian so I feel like an
impostor
so okay this is so oh this is why are we
really getting into this this is great
because I think that this is about
self-doubt right
so you doubt yourself yeah you don't
feel like you get enough never okay so
this is there you go these are all the
leads of things these are things you can
attack if you attack them like a nurse
yeah like you know like a scientist you
listen what you're saying you're going
like I don't believe I belong here so
maybe that was like even when you were a
nurse you were like you know did you did
it happen it was was there any point any
point where you were like I am super
confident about what I'm doing and who I
am I'm super confident in what I knew
and like I said like in theory like you
couldn't give me a disease process I
couldn't break down for you I just
couldn't I just couldn't work with my
hands okay but again that's still
there's still the avenues to go into
using there's a lot of things yeah I I
think I was I but why don't you think
you did you think that you couldn't
actually be a nurse I could have been
some type of nurse see look how you say
that it's such such doubt in your voice
I'm like some type just not somebody
like could have been like a public
health nurse I could have been someone
who did more like nursing education for
families and stuff like that but not not
bedside not in the ICU where I wanted to
be that's disappointing
it's disappointing yeah and I put that
own expectation on myself no one else
did I just thought that I needed to be a
hotshot if I was gonna be a nurse I
needed to be a hotshot how do you know
that you wouldn't have been a hotshot I
can't that's like a basic requirement
for like handling any type of like you
know medical procedure is a real thing
like you're saying that like give me a
wear gloves latex gloves right now we'll
test out my view no I'm just saying my
the thought process here is that you
literally can't put gloves on and that's
why you're not a high powered nurse
right now yeah I'll tell you why even
something like starting an IV putting in
a catheter putting in a rectal tube my
hands would be drip
I was making cake batter inside my pair
of gloves if I could even get them on
because I had put on so much baby powder
I had made cake batter on there and it
was such a secret that I kept from all
my peers in nursing school because
everyone people thought wow she's so
smart she aces the exams she knows
everything and everything she could talk
your ear off about nursing birthday cake
but do you think do you not you don't
have any regrets of like hiding that
because have you have you ever secretly
done some research to be like something
I could do about this yes there was this
one respiratory therapist who was like
oh I have sweaty hands too and I'm like
what do you do and that's why he was
like you know baby powder so I did that
I put a [ __ ] you know thread a little
bag of baby powder and that [ __ ]
backfired and made cake there was no
other techniques Botox for six years
Oh got you I've done everything oh but
you do in the Botox now just for
yourself no no no I don't do it anymore
when you bouncing before me it wasn't
because you were doing nursing you would
just like it just became like the bane
of your existence yeah it's only good
for giving hand jobs that's honestly the
only thing it's good for and I don't
know if you noticed but I have really
pretty hands it's it's moisturize it
over the years and I have really young
looking hands because of it because my
knuckles sweat this is like a weird like
there's gonna be people out there like
my knuckles sweat - you're gonna be like
the knuckles sweat advocate person I
have you not okay so you people when
they think that okay sweaty hands this
is really mild right now but they think
that the palms only the palms sweat just
drenched mm-hm
damn well gonna show you my feet look
how sweaty they are a way to get like I
have knuckles something on there no
don't because there's a sweat see the no
no it's like the thing that was on the
ground
you know why it stuck to my foot because
my feet are sweating sweaty appendages
you have old newspapers oh man okay well
alright this is a thing you read such
merripit no I I get like that to that
see you wanna bet I bet you if I put my
my hand underneath your head nothing my
god lose it it's not a good size so you
don't like going like the beach
vacations could you just get or I said
that's perfect to go to some way because
you should be sweating there okay okay
okay so alright okay let's move the [ __ ]
on from my sweaty hands of nurse nurse
alright but I do feel like if you want
to go in the medical field you can and
there's a way for you to do it and I but
the other issue talking about regardless
of being wanted to be a nurse is this
feeling that you're not good enough to
be anything Yeah right so that was the
thing that has to be overcome because
that's not true because you know Tiger
belly is great it's not just because of
Bobby like don't fool yourself don't
think that you don't add value to that
dynamic you know so well that's why I
don't really I'm not really upset about
it but if it was horrible you'd be oh
yeah of course cuz it would be your
fault
but no it's like no you you know you you
see the good comments to the people say
it's like it's not it's not you have to
know that that worked that was magic it
obviously like in he knew it too when
once you can once you guys got rolling
it was like oh we really got something
here so you can't sit there and be like
well I bring nothing to this it's not
true at all I mean it's just it's the
reason why it wasn't just Andrew and I
coming on Tiger belly guest-hosting that
made it like that it was because you
made it easy to sit in that chair
you know so you have to know that you
actually could go do your own podcast if
you wanted to you could just like you
know I mean you could be like you could
do it with anyone and then you know
it'll work yeah you know so you just
have to know that that's a thing yeah
are there anything are their dreams
nursing dreams you had me nursing no not
nursing yeah you know what I don't know
because I didn't know what I wanted to
do because I can you had this pressure
like my mom was always pressuring me
like you know you need you know school
you gotta finish college you wanted me
to be something you know what I mean but
ultimately she just wanted me to be
happy like be you know be great at
something or you know and then like when
you're looking at society you're like oh
well I guess that has to be a lawyer a
doctor or a business person you know and
then like entertainment business is just
a pipe dream you know when I was first
telling her like I think I want to do
this she was like oh no I don't but but
I'll never forget my mom came to I did
this like improv acting class at UCLA
Extension and we had like a showcase and
my mom came to the showcase and
afterwards she was like oh you really
could do this you know and I think she
needed that for herself to be like an
athlete she was like gung-ho about like
you should go do this go do that so
these classes and she just now she was
like super supportive yeah so I mean
it's just you know so I know when I was
a little kid I said I wanted to be a
comedian I said that to my mom even
though I don't remember that but you
know so I guess I'm doing what I wanted
to do but I have regrets too cuz I
stopped I I had fear that I was like I
can't do this how long did you stop and
win like eight years you stopped for
eight yes I start I started doing comedy
like in my early early 20s and then I
just was like going to open mics in LA
and it was terrible you know cuz then I
was so arrogant it was just like I'm
funny and then you go to back to the
open mic II like oh it's the same people
doing the same jokes yeah stupid I'm
gonna get on that stage I want to do
this but I didn't know how to do it I
didn't know how to like navigate my
psyche and and how I you know / you know
you know talk about things I just hadn't
had any
nothing was developed yet and I just
didn't have it I just was scared of
failure I didn't want to be on stage and
people liked it I was gonna boo me or
like be like you suck or no one laughs I
didn't know how to deal with that and I
didn't deal with it until I was much
older yeah so you know it's but I have
regrets for that but maybe maybe that's
what you need it though I mean I know
that regrets about like feeling like you
know you wasted eight years that you
could have contributed to even being
like you know a better performer now but
maybe you weren't at that age or at that
mindset or at that maturity to really
tackle it the way you should have
tackled it to be well I know but I look
but I can I look back on though those
were just I let I can look back on and
be like oh man I let my fear get in the
way the things you're talking about now
it's just like that's just how I dealt
with it how I overcame it now yeah but I
can still look back and be like damn it
I should have done this yeah you know I
why did I let myself like like wait so
long yeah yeah you know what I mean it's
okay to look back because that's how you
learn from your mistakes yeah you know
so it's just like that's what I'm saying
to you it's like you know you can still
it's never too late to do anything right
you know I mean it's never too late
because you're just like oh because I
always feel like I want to go to school
myself I feel like I want to go to
school and then like become a
psychologist do you ever feel that way I
always feel like I'm getting Dumber do
you feel that way I don't feel like
we're getting dumber I feel like we're
not thirsting for knowledge anymore like
I I think that the reason that I have
this desire to go back to school is
because I I do feel like I'm falling
behind like all these you know I feel
like I'm falling behind compared to
everybody that's currently in school or
I'm like [ __ ] like I remember being in
college and just absorbing absorbing
absorbing and I'm always in that you
know I go to school every day and
something is new I go home and there's
something to mull over right right I
don't I don't have that anymore I don't
feel I have this fear that it's just all
you know those synapses that I built for
so long in school are now weakening and
eventually I'll just lose it
or they're developed to the point now
where information is coming to you and
you're processing it fast and you don't
realize it you know like it's not just
like when you were in the environment
where you were taken in all this
information about things you that's the
environment you're in yeah I think if
you put your but I think you're still in
that environment it's just in a
different way
because like when you sit down with in
talk for hours with people like twice a
week you know you're you're you're now
you're just processing faster you know
it's like oh I got that I think if you
went back to school right now
you may still not feel that feeling that
you felt because you're gonna be like oh
I know how to do this you know I read
this book I write this paper I do this
you know you just your shelves and your
brain are organized now yeah you're just
like okay that goes here this goes here
that goes here this goes here and you're
just like moving and grooving that's
what happens as we get older yeah but
when you get older your brains on is
like pliable yeah but you're not you're
talking about 50 60 70 years old dead
it's dying I'm saying you would have
made a great psychologist or a therapist
or a psychiatrist or whatever anything
in that field or a social worker I think
that you have that in you
you're a very good listener and you are
very comforting person to be your own
well you know I appreciate that but I
have started to think about that because
but see that's why I had to go to
therapy and like work on boundaries and
things like that you know because it's
like you know you can't if you're like
this people pick up on that are you two
dumping ground for emotions oh me too
yes and then people just like you know I
have like I had this friend of mine just
just girl that I and she and then she
like something happened in their life
you know and then I could just text like
you she tried to call me I was like well
I I couldn't didn't answer then I got a
text message like yeah it's really
urgent you know and I'll say urgent like
I don't even know you that well what's
so urgent you know and then we start
talking and it was just that something
happened at her job and she just needed
to talk to me just because I
occasionally
what happened you know well I think you
could do this don't worry about this and
I was just helping her organize her
thought I was just like Danis a lot it
is alive that's a lot it's so like but
I'm more aware of it now how much it is
that I'm kind of like yo yo yo I'm not
here for that for everybody that's death
boundaries you know yeah I I think
that's fair and that's why I don't
understand when people have liked me and
when they say like they have like thirty
friends thirty realities I'm like how
the [ __ ] the other time they're not
friends they're not the level of
friendship that I require to call
someone a friend is very deep like it's
you know you take me to the airport at
least six times in my life what I mean I
need airport love you gotta get it uber
it doesn't no no no it's still the same
I don't listen I'm gonna take you to the
airport
it doesn't make you feel special what if
someone takes you it's not a feeling you
have not not any only reason why it made
you feel special before is because you
know how expensive a cab is and it's
like where I still expect you to know
but it's not it's it's but that's a part
of life now people Oberer places now so
like it's actually rude to ask somebody
to take you like get the [ __ ] out of
here it's not your phone man Bobby
requires that out of me I have to be
waiting at the airport and I have to be
in the right spot leaving him at the
base of the elevator first of all him
and I this is why him and I are such
close friends I know exactly what he's
talking about
okay like I get you I'm watching ass and
it cuz you know what cuz I do that yeah
when I go to the airport if your flight
comes in at 5:00 and I'm at the airport
at 5:00 okay I'm sorry I'm there for 30
because it's a post 9-11 world okay I'm
at the airport I'm parked you know um
this is me when you coming down the
escalator I'm like I'm here because I
just know how it is to travel yeah I
know I travel all the time so I know how
it is to get off a plane and you just to
see that familiar face yeah when I first
was with Rachel we were
I had to tell her like no you can't pick
me up because the one time she came to
pick me up I was like it's I have a
procedure yeah it's like I get off the
thing here Park what III told it this is
where you should Park no she want to
part like down the thing I'm like nah
unless you want to have an attitude
about it like well you know what you can
just over I say oh I know I'm just going
over okay so now I understand because
one time I was five minutes late and I
wasn't at the base of the elevator with
coffee in my hand to receive Bobby and
he's getting really intense with coffee
thank you you know the coffee beans
right next oh yeah and he was really
upset and I never he's never been high
maintenance like that no but no no it's
it's I totally get it
because you know what what is it it's
not hard for you as the person picking
somebody up like come on have some
sympathy for this person who probably
dealt with some [ __ ] on a flight
like just they're sitting there they're
dealing with other people that getting
to the airport waking up and when you
get off that plane it is very refreshing
to see your loved one yeah they're ready
to go not what you were made a mistake
one time and you know what he said what
yeah you don't know how to do it yeah I
do it just wave me off you're gonna
[ __ ] do anything I'm like oh my god
that was just his travel yeah yeah but I
can't stand when people call you you
land and they go they go um text me when
you land
yeah oh no I guess what my flight comes
in Fi I don't need to text you okay I'll
let you know yes I've landed and your
ass should be there yeah you know what I
mean because that's just so we consider
it to be standing on the curb
waiting for somebody right I don't even
do that I don't even do that
like if I'm picking you this what what
I'm picking you up for the airport I
[ __ ] part I Part two it's three
dollars
yeah I actually it stresses me out to
pick people up I don't like all that
traffic right there
yeah it's easier to get out of the
airport and first of all they give you
15 minutes free anyway yeah so you work
it out right you park you walk in the
[ __ ] walking off the plane the
bags there we go and you drive right out
if not it's three [ __ ] dollars yeah
you know what I mean I can't stand that
people and then these people get mad
they dated why I was circling that's so
much more work exactly the worst the
worst it's the worst of the worst
freaking Airport but I don't know what
we were talking about but I friendship
levels of friendship Airport friendship
levels of friendship now I agree with
you completely about that's why I don't
let chicks tell me like oh I just want
to be friends cuz I'm like oh you don't
get to dictate the terms of our
relationship because like I don't know
what you think friends are but I don't
text my guy friends like hey what's up
was just thinking about you know this is
a courting situation yeah and if the
courting is not gonna go that way and
you want to be friends time for you to
step up and be friends yeah so what's
your part in the friendship so people
don't even know like you know what you
would never say you never hear about
somebody go I want a one-night friend a
one-night friend what's that like oh I
know what those are I think I had one
no no what obviously no no what I'm
saying is this is like isn't it strange
that you would have sex with a stranger
someone you just met
mm-hmm right you would do that but like
I don't just go oh we're now good
friends like I would just meet you to be
like I'm gonna you're gonna be the the
my best friend in the world in one night
you wouldn't do that friendship takes
time to build yeah right yeah I think
all the people that I have in my life
have I've been have been around for at
least 10 years yeah and there's a lot of
give-and-take and a lot of work put into
all my friendships
I treasure my friendships deeply I don't
have a big circle but it's a very tight
circle it's a very loving circle and I
would bend over backwards and pick all
of them up from the airport
well that just happens over time you
take you have you the big thing about
just picking up from the airport maybe
you should be a kid your hands are too
sweaty for the steering wheel a kid
can't do anything I have a question how
much of on your show or any podcast you
talked about like your personal life or
your girlfriend and things like that I
try not to I made a mistake once when I
was still with Rachel my girlfriend
I wasn't rogen and then like I sent her
age yeah and it was like God mm-hmm like
as I said it I was like oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have said that
yeah you know so I just it was just like
yeah then it was just like you know cuz
we were taught at the time we were
talking about how like you know she
didn't want to say how old she was and
blah blah blah and I don't know it just
so then after that I was just like just
out of respect I try not to cuz it's
like Who am I did I talk about
somebody's personal business yeah but I
mean like you don't even talk about it
like surface-level about it's hard
because when you start talking about it
you tend to like have to give reference
like you have to be like you know well
I'm this way well this is what happened
yeah then I'm revealing information so
it's it's hard I talk about my own
personal things with my family I talk
about my mom a lot like having dementia
I talk about these kinda things but in
terms of like my personal life it's hard
to it's hard to get into those things
without like revealing more than I want
to about someone else's business
especially in this setting because it
always it's dangerous I always find that
you know every time we record a podcast
like why the [ __ ] did I say that yeah
because you forget that you're not just
talking to your friends I know so easy
to fall into that yeah you go deeper and
deeper until you you're like oh [ __ ] now
I you know everyone knows the [ __ ]
color of her nipples like yeah
but see those kind of things is like I
don't think that that's I don't really
think those are the things you're
talking about I think it's easy to hide
behind those things you know what I mean
I just personally think that like you
know especially in comedy like you know
society where we're afraid of femininity
you know we're so afraid of it
they don't want we don't want to admit
how scary and uncomfortable that makes
us feel it's the reason why female
comics always have to dress down and
like ponytails and jeans and like almost
a boy you know what I mean yeah but then
like masculinity can be onstage and it
could just you could just be like like
the head of it you know you sort of
a-type personality comics like Chris
D'Elia for instance he's just like you
know he's an attractive rugged dude he's
up there and his masculinity is coming
through his comedy and all the women in
the crowd are like I want this guy you
know but like it doesn't work the same
opposite like if there's a woman on
there she's got you know a nice body and
whatever it is like that it becomes like
like a distraction as opposed to
enhancing the experience yeah it's
unfortunate I I think that girl should
dress however the [ __ ] they want to do
onstage but you know when you talk about
femininity it's I I wonder I wish men
would kind of lean into their feminine
side a little bit more it's there I have
a masculine side all chicks do and you
know it's praised when we you know lean
into our masculine sign you're like yeah
she's a dope ass chick she's doing I'm
talking I mean she can roll with the
boys or whatever right but when like my
male best friend is someone that I can
shop with he he will tell me straight up
if I look a hot mess Express he's like
nope take that [ __ ] off you know you
look horrible like he's I love that in
men I find that very attractive in men
well I think that like again I just I
think we're talking about the same thing
because I think that that is like what
is you know a you know we get this whole
thing is like oh you're gay like I had
to cut something out of my podcast with
Bobby when he with him with his brother
so I do this bit about Disney you know
and then for no reason Bobby knows you
know when you're singing you know that
thing is it's very gay
it comes off gay he said that to me and
I was like I got so mad at him yeah cuz
I'll say what the [ __ ] you talking about
yeah you you were a song and and lap
dance a dude on stage it's really
exciting Nick I didn't know where that
it just came it was so out of like like
I don't know where that I was like but
that vibe yeah is why men tend to like
not like lean into that part even though
it's there all the time yeah you know
it's like I'm a diva I didn't realize
this until my ex-girlfriend said this to
me you know you know cuz she was like at
the Comedy Store and then like Brian
Williams wife no no she wasn't with me
and Bradley was a pleasure girl and I
was like oh cause we have a support Club
for like you know women I remember that
she I have spoken to her yeah she was a
pro kleh and then I told her all about I
was like hey you know she wants to you
know and she was like oh this one this
one Rachel said she was like I need that
because I need to know like how do they
deal with your travel and how do they
deal with your diva behavior you know oh
you know what yes I am demanding and and
like I want things a certain way and
like you know and it is so I guess that
you know I don't know what that is but
like I wish we would lived in a society
that it was okay to like all of your
parts of you without it being like
judged yeah yeah I I think that oh my
god I loved I love when I love that
about you I think that's what I find
comforting about you it's why I'm
probably able to talk you know woman
come here baby
my everyday look I I have very like
rugged masculine friends and you know
who I'm very close with but you know we
talk about like spearfishing
you know namine like and that requires
me to turn on my masculine side then
they love that about me but the people
that I am the men that I really really
adore are the ones who are not afraid to
be soft do you think that that's why a
lot of women have like a gay friend like
a super gay friend oh yeah yeah we all
do but there's still something but then
but then there is still something
missing from that because you're like
yeah I love that you're a guy and you
can pick out the right colour scheme but
there's still a party that also wants a
guy that's like you know hey girl you
know yeah with that yeah I think that's
right I probably found that most
attractive about Bobby that he was you
know right now we're decorating our
bedroom and he likes pink sheets you
know he likes he wants a pink wall like
he's you know what just not particularly
he was about what he wanted the house to
look like yeah that's why it took so
long yeah
to find it he I just just went high he
was telling me I was like dude why are
you obsessing over this this is what I
want you know so it's like I get it I
mean but don't you think that there are
different relationships like like there
are things we appreciate about a certain
friend that you have that this person is
this way and it's like I'm glad that
person's that way it doesn't have yeah I
wouldn't want all my friends to be
multifaceted yeah you know sometimes you
want to be with the you got that high
girlfriend just because you know yeah
it's the same reason why I watch love
Island or Real Housewives of I'm a big
brother fan look I watched diagnosis
yeah I watch [ __ ] smart shows like
you know smart comedies once in a while
I'm gonna have to turn in that yeah and
it's just because I don't want my brain
to fire you know and sometimes when I
want just a night of no questions and no
philosophizing yeah I need a Stacy
especially when it's hard when you're
like always doing a podcast and this is
always stimulating your brain like this
is very stimulating conversation right
now it's like even when even when it's
being silly
our brains are working into like you
know you know sometimes yeah that's why
I don't know how you guys do it as often
as you do like every night yeah yeah but
also like the interactions that you have
to have every night with very similar
minds of that just the chaotic nature
yeah I mean that [ __ ] is you're either
hardwired to do it or you're not I'm not
that's why I do my podcast once a week
and that is my maximum is my max that's
why when you were like come on let's do
scorpion labs like do I have it in me
well we just have to find what it should
be like it doesn't have like this is a
Griffin with Griffin episode like I
don't want our thing to be necessarily
like this no no I wanted to be more
quickfire buh-buh-buh maybe we take like
like I said I thought we maybe we take
like a video question from someone and
all right we just we break it down and
then we're done like that's that's it
for this week and I see you next week I
mean I totally get it but it's like yes
sometimes that don't I don't want to be
stimulated all the time either and I
just I play video games because of that
you know what I mean do you feel like
video games just allow you to shut down
certain parts of yourself and just have
like one primary focus I think that
video games provide like it keeps my
brain active and working without but in
the back but not in the front like a
like a awake Idol yeah yes yes like on
neutral yes yeah and so on that's why
I'm still because I'm still I'm still
exercising my brain and I working on
hand-eye coordination and keeping my
meaning but if they cuz I cuz I pry
myself and be able to think fast I got
it like buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
which is like to get personal is a
problem I have like with you know my ex
is like we don't think on the same speed
you know doesn't mean that it's like you
know and that's important sometimes like
sometimes you we don't get to this
place at the same time but you know that
that's frustrating it's frustrating but
I I've found over over time that that's
not a mark of like there's not that
doesn't mean a discrepancy in
intelligence I don't think because I
used to think that talkers I'm like come
on like get it together but then from
being honest that's not the same way to
just to say that out loud while I'm let
you finish but like yes you do think
that you can go like this person is good
stupid because they not it's not that
yeah it's not that at all
we're just I just started to race a lot
sooner and I just buy it from it my
processing power was iPad and that's why
you have really good thoughtful writers
who aren't who aren't necessarily
dynamic in conversation but that's just
because they get to that place a little
slower and I used to think I used to get
the same frustration with people will
might just spit it out yeah what is the
general thesis of what you're trying to
say but then I started hanging around
you [ __ ] and you guys are fast
and I feel slow and that's what really
humbled me where I'm like wow I can't
keep up with none of these people and
that's when I realize oh I'm not at the
speed that they operate the people that
I I'm frustrated with they're not at the
speed that I operate somewhere in the
middle but they're like my sister my
sister someone who's very like
introverted a little bit more quiet but
she has the vocabulary like you wouldn't
believe she is so well-read she is so
just she talks like she's she's from the
1800s
very like proper English very just just
brighter than me in all regards but she
is she doesn't speak as fast as I do or
as emphatically mm-hmm but she is the
brighter sister well sometimes people
are also emotionally slow like Bobby's
like that he may be like that with you
now because you guys have been together
for so long but he's for sure like I
could like emotionally he's a stump
he's developmentally stunted when it
comes to understanding other people's
emotions but his
own he is he knows his own emotions and
he's a quick feelers we just described
he's selfish a fancy way of calling
their little [ __ ] selfish he is selfish
sometimes he's very still he's very
she's very like you know yeah cuz it'll
be like Bobby we need to do this at this
time and he's just like you like that he
tried to [ __ ] me over with that meeting
yeah I mean like he's like you know you
know it's like that's just how he just
so he said he understands his emotions
yeah very well very well
right he understands his most of why he
feels like life like I totally get him
like when he was telling the story one
time about going on set to a new set and
then the lady it was like oh are you
background and took him to the
background people and he sat there and
waited yeah and I know why he did you
know so that's an advanced thought
process I'm like okay you're gonna treat
me like this I'm gonna show you what I'm
gonna do okay but sometimes it's like yo
man I need you to like get back to me
yeah I need you to return my calls you
know as I need you to be like I'm
reaching out to you and so so in the
same way we're talking about people's
intelligence level that doesn't mean he
loves any less it doesn't I I'd you know
them yeah I I just think that you know
there's a book of like five love
languages oh I love the long way was
just [ __ ] good love language this is my
[ __ ] man I don't think that applies to
certain Koreans I really don't think it
does what do you think Bobby this has
Bobby done a love language test because
I bet you have first one on his is acts
of service what is it
what act of service no no his love
languages he was CEO he receives yes as
acts of service and probably access
service you're right sure because that's
my number one to um and I'm I'm the same
yeah oh that's okay well they give me
him to do [ __ ] for you I don't need many
types like very much formation she have
my my thing right here my acts of
service okay what are the five again I'm
I tell you right now we can go to it
right now we can't get her to me
okay so mine are in order are acts of
service physical touch words of
affirmation quality time and receiving
gifts those are my five in a row
importance can I see that
[Music]
okay so I'll tell you my order my number
one is actually not acts of service
oh my number one detest though you can't
just guess it no because I've read this
before and I remember reading it it's
about you have to answer all those
questions because how you answer those
questions will determine how how they
come up with this thing it's important
cuz oh you know what I'm taste them
right now when you're taking the test
those questions the way they did their
worded yeah it's so important for like
your own cuz you start to go oh wow yeah
this is more yeah
but I'm telling you right now that words
of affirmation really it's not my thing
neither is receiving gifts not even from
my own family is the last thing yeah
it's the last thing for me you know like
thank you but I don't physically touch
guy number two John physically your
number one you never know um and that's
the thing that I've compromised a little
too much in in my relationship with
Bobby's because I wanted to be I wanted
to be the cool chick in the beginning
like in the first year and I wanted to
go with whatever he was comfortable with
he was affectionate but he's like a cat
he doesn't he'll come to you when he
comes to come yeah yeah it's never when
you think yeah yeah I know I'm teeing
[ __ ] he knows not the time to rub up
against my leg you know what I mean yeah
and so I think physical touch and
quality time and acts of service are
probably almost equal with one another
there that's it I want you to take the
test I will you just want you to take
your test we should like you know that's
you know we should do on our first
episode of scorpion lashes
you're taking the test what's what's it
gonna reveal we get the results but I
miss her whoa no well I mean like I
realized do you think that these this
love language thing is important for a
couple I just don't think that it it
applies to a lot of people one thing
that I really pissed me off about the
book too
was it only referred to it to men like I
forgot what it was but they didn't
really yeah I remember maybe it was like
some outdated version of the book but I
was like I find it very helpful in terms
of like because my ex she took that we
took it together what was hers it was
like you know it was physical touch
receiving gifts but here's the thing
when you hear that like when you keep
like people that like receiving gifts
okay if that's their love language yeah
we have this opinion about it you know
it's like oh you just but I'm telling
you if that's the person's love language
yeah I'm talking about a Starbucks gift
card yeah anything flowers like if the
person is they were like receiving gifts
the way they respond it's worth doing
yeah because I think it's not about the
gift itself it's about the
thoughtfulness though exactly but I'm
just saying no when people's love
language is an important tool it helps
it you know I would love to see what
Bobby's like if he did it now that I
think about it it's receiving gifts
because you know for his birthday this
is what he did to me Eric and I clutched
I wanted to be in town but I was out of
town we didn't do anything anything oh
you did I thought you guys were having a
big dinner for him no but he was feeling
still a little morose about his dad and
stuff like that sounds I guess he didn't
feel it didn't feel like a year of
celebration so oh yeah we just kept it
low-key but he said you know I had got
this cake made for him and it was a
three-tiered cake and he had a collage
of all his pictures and I also got him
like the mint chocolate ice cream cake
that he wanted and I got it
anyways I thought that that would be
enough and that I would take it
to dinner because he said he wanted
something low-key but it turns out the
night before I was like what would make
you happy he was a golden goose shoes or
a Moncler jacket and I was like are you
kidding
and he's like no like I'm not I'm not
kidding like I if it's not any of those
two I will not receive your gift I
refuse to take yet take anything less
and so the next morning I scrambled over
it to golden goose you know those
[ __ ] shoes they're like six seven
hundred dollars yeah I'm like crying on
my way out because it's just a very
painful purchase to make you know how
your cheap Filipino it's just not in a
regular person's budget okay you
[ __ ] have the money and that
way I would never buy myself a pair of
$700 shoes when he received it the joy
in his face was just unmatched and it
made me happy that's what I'm saying
dried my tears but I'm saying he's such
a weirdo yeah like you know it's like
he's he literally is my weirdest friend
like it's the most complicated
relationship but people need to stop
telling him that because I think that he
revels in that fatboys I think that it
becomes such his identity to be to be
this very eccentric artist selfish
crafty you know like allowing you but we
need to stop praising it and make it
something that makes him we've talked
about it so much that he thinks those
are the interesting parts about him you
know what you want this is gonna be our
you know but maybe our podcast should be
about fixing Bobby Bobby how to fix
about you know because my it's yeah cuz
my favorite times with him are where we
go eat after the comedy store and we're
just sitting there and he's sitting
across the table from me
and we're just talking about stuff and
he's just so interesting you know we're
interested in each other's thoughts and
we know you know you know I'm like oh
this is my friend right here and that's
why I get so frustrated the other times
when I'm like who are you right now who
the [ __ ] are you being what are you
doing you know like at the Konami store
he's like you know being this character
he's he loves being a character of
himself and just not being himself I
always tell him there's this rule in the
house before he walks into the door he
has to take his mask off oh so he knows
it is so big he has to wear that heavy
mask whatever who he is when he's just
with me hmm
is something that I treasure so deeply I
don't care to describe it to people I
told you know what I totally get it
yeah I totally get it because I had the
same thing with him so I know exactly
what you mean yeah that's why so [ __ ]
annoying what is not like that exactly
so jarring yes like okay you're not but
that part of him is so precious yeah
that you like okay I'll put up with this
other [ __ ] yeah and I think that's
either the most the most special thing
in the world are the most manipulative
thing in the world I can't I can't quite
figure it out because even when we first
met I found our connection something
that I never cared to explain to people
because it just we just meshed I never I
can never describe that why I loved
Bobby it was just when it was just him
and I it we just clicked we didn't have
to explain ourselves to the other and he
always says that he's like I feel like
I've known you you know my whole life
and I feel the same way about him well
that's nice but the floor drops but when
he puts that mask back on and he goes to
another place and he tells everyone all
my business is when we first started
dating and dating and I'm like who the
[ __ ] does this guy think he is I know it
was
remember actually yeah when he went on
David thing that he reveal I said he
shouldn't reveal it was the most
treasonous thing I'd ever is a great
word should never be treasonous like
imagine that imagine just having this
conversation about you know I am NOT
ready to have a child I have a heart
condition and doing this and we're
having this genuine moment of like
deciding you know whether or not you
should like terminate a pregnancy having
you know shedding tears about it
together and saying okay it's just not
our time and then like when you're in
the clinic finally getting it done and
someone Texas you like Hey Dude your
guys just talking about how here about
the killer baby you know like yeah when
did you when did you make the choice
that you were okay with all that with
what with him like why do you said it's
like we have so many precious moments
together yeah but what I'm saying it had
to be a point where you were like there
has to be a point where you go I could
put up with all that or you could have
been like oh hell no I can't do this is
I can I won't be able to deal with this
but you know what Stan's wife left him
because he was like that on the radio
just you know I mean I don't know if
that's actually the whole reason but I'm
just saying I remember even from the
movie he was talking about you know his
wife who just got sick of all that yeah
I mean it was so years a certain point
for you that you were like well you
actually joined in and there was a he
explained to me that in order if I
wanted to if he put it this way he's
like this is my life I I you know my
comedy is drawn from sad to say but even
like my personal stuff and I don't know
if I have the discipline to leave you
out of it completely because you know
relationships you know our relationship
is such a massive part of my day and a
massive part of my life and so takes up
so much of my mental space and my heart
space that how can I possibly keep it
out yeah that's so honest and so I'm
like okay so exactly what are we gonna
just check in this this sound keep going
I'm sorry exactly what are we going to
be saying
me he was like are you gonna be okay
with everything and I'm like I don't
know let's see yeah and I was like if
you if you're gonna say something about
me and reveal something about me try to
balance it out and like say some nice
things pay me is a baby killer you know
what I mean
and then it was solely my decision so
just you know like throw through some
words of affirmation which is obviously
one of your love languages
maybe but accidentally I found it
freeing accidentally I found it to be
whoa like it really is not a big deal
for people to know like those surface
things about me because those are the
surface things about me those that isn't
my my that isn't my soul and I know this
is gonna be really hard to believe but
what I put out in our podcast and Tiger
belly is not my soul and my friends can
attest to that right right right
they know me so differently so so
differently what's become like evolved
you guys have cuz cuz like wouldn't
Bobby has a now he has a podcast persona
yeah don't we all
Yeah right so now it's an hour now it's
like so then you've established your own
right and you know what that is and
people hate trolls hate this especially
about me but I will maintain it this
persona until the day I die is that I am
antagonistic with Bobby and I will throw
him under the bus for as long as I live
because that is what he responds to it's
what elicits the best comedy out of him
is to not be lovey-dovey you go ahead
and try to be lovey-dovey with Bobby he
will [ __ ] you know he'll punch you in
the vagina and tell you to leave the
room he responds the best to being
antagonized and that's the same with you
and I think that's why you guys you know
work well together
it's like insult after insult yeah there
we go but then there's like you know
that you know even though my tender
moment from him was the first time I'm
seeing him say something nice to me
publicly you [ __ ] cut sucker
that was not my doing when I saw that I
myself was flabbergasted as a what does
Gilbert have against me
to be fair Gilbert Gilbert hadn't slept
in three days he had taken a choice
because he felt genuinely bad and he
even said it's Eric piss and as I don't
think is that big of a deal oh here's
another funny jokes yeah when when
Bobby's father passed away Gilbert was
flying back from Chicago when Gilbert
landed Bobby said everyone has to fly to
Arizona tonight to record a podcast
because I want to record a podcast but
we didn't think he wanted to all right
we didn't he was right we were just
gonna wait you know wait it out
so Gilbert lands from LAX go straight to
Burbank Airport goes to Arizona we
record this podcast at like 1a I saw
that one yeah yeah yeah and then we fly
back the next day at 7 a.m. and then he
has to upload it quickly and edit it
he's like it was just one giant blur for
him he just put the ads wherever the
[ __ ] he thought I'm so sorry you were
the just that seems to I don't believe
that I think he I think there was a part
of him that was like this would be funny
Bobby's finally excuse me guys it's like
this [ __ ] man [ __ ] well you know
what I think we're at a good cuz I feel
like we you know you and I feel like we
can just Yap forever yeah we should
really cut this Yap forever I do
appreciate you coming over and coming on
and we'll figure out I know how you you
know we'll figure the guys we're gonna
figure out something fun and light to do
for our scorpion lashes especially if
Bobby is daring to do a podcast with
Andrew Santino which I honestly if they
do what they do it what is it ever gonna
be but see Bobby I the thing is I've
called Bobby privately he knows cuz I
know how he would feel
if it was him in my position and I know
he knows how I feel like him and I are
similar that way you know it's a small
slice he's sensitive about like he takes
things personal because he's this big
picture of like you know so so I'm a
little bit like that I'm not as far gone
as he is but just a little bit of like
you know you feel you feel like oh so
you don't want to do it with me why
don't you want to do it with me how come
we didn't do it how come we're not gonna
do it you know to me so there is a what
anybody would feel that way naturally if
something that we've been talking about
for so long and then all of a sudden I
get this call like oh this is really
gonna happen and boom I'm like wait a
minute what happened you know me so you
take a little personal he was a little
sensitive you and about you and I doing
it that's very good that's exactly you
know what secretly that's why I did it
[Applause]
this is my only way to get back in and
since I've said yeah yeah I think Eric
and I we'll all of a sudden his interest
to do one with a Santino has waned a
little bit [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah beige and brown you know only in
the summertime this is we're gonna all
work it out we'll figure the next thing
you know we're doing a group podcast and
it's all four of us and I do not want to
be a part of that I don't to be a part
of it either honestly I don't know if I
would have been able to handle this one
thing well part of this face yeah I
don't know about every day but I handle
even doing a podcast with Bobby but I
guess I get but I do like I've like
Steve's another one like I have to see
what I have Steve on like he's a lot you
know so every unit I mean so they're
just a lot the Lee brothers are a lot
you know just a lot so but they're so
entertaining you know what I mean it's
just fun to I you I like being in their
satellite you know the you know you know
around their their orbit around them you
know
yeah they just find guys to be around
and so are you listen I I think that I
the enclosing I think that you should
stop get off your ass and make some
efforts to get back into the medical
field in some form another don't use the
excuses forgive yourself you know what I
mean you know you were great at it so do
it find a way to do it and overcome
those things you are good enough you
know you're you're great at doing
podcast
you really are she is you are you good
at this don't act like you're not cuz
you are you're good you and when I watch
Tiger belly I'm like oh I get it
that's so important your dynamic is
important with him it makes it what it
is it's part of the magic you know I
mean so know your worth in that and I
thank you for coming on this is Lila
Lila right telling you yeah
kalila Kuhn from Tiger belly's my friend
actually I'll say that even more
importantly than my podcast buddy is my
friend can work I don't I don't trust it
you're gonna have the coffee right
subscribe I'm have all the information
below and thanks for watching and
listening to riff for girlfriend I'll
see you next week
[Music]